all right folks is like this I'm a guy a
simple taste I like me a couple things
Mortal Kombat and Super Smash Brothers
so I got to play it here at PAX I got to
say like okay I'm a huge Smash Brothers
fan I love me Super Smash Brothers and
in playing Super Smash Brothers you got
to play characters that you're familiar
with so you can kind of size up how
they're different
I Blake Donkey Kong because I'm not too
bad at Donkey Kong and they had Donkey
Kong to be playable Donkey Kong's was
why in depth takes a little longer but
it still hits like a truck one thing I
love it's really fast it's really
exciting everything you love about Super
Smash Brothers a lot of items on which I
think it's [ __ ] how pitches that
people beat you with an item no that's
not real that's not legit however one
thing did happen I snapped to the left I
was gonna go after someone and I didn't
trip I didn't trip at all because the
tripping is gone because the tripping
and Super Smash Brothers Brawl was
stupid and everyone here know there's a
girl laughing right there you can't see
her you're laughing because you know the
tripping stupid yeah hey China is a
tripping stupid very stupid because the
tripping was I don't have so Super Smash
Brothers for the I went right for the
Wii U I didn't play his 3ds version I
wanted to didn't have time but the Wii U
version looks great I play this little
Mac little Mac hits like a truck he's
like a little Balrog all right imagine
Balrog he was tiny and he just rock
induced with his gloves it seemed to me
and again this is just kind of a
downfall of being able to play a little
bit of a demo and not play for you know
two hours is the fact that he hit hard
but he didn't seem to hit them out of
the rings so I'm curious to see how that
works out if he's gonna be like Sonic
the Hedgehog or if he's gonna be like
Meta Knight where you can't really hit
him out people who say they can you're
lying to me they even had the GameCube
controllers here because they know
what's awesome GameCube controllers no
tripping Smash Brothers as fast it's
exciting I can't wait I'm gonna get it
for both systems because why wouldn't I
you will too
got hello Smash Brothers
you